I'm did a lot peace be with you welcome
to the DS show a wonderful episode today
Eid Mubarak will reaching the end of
Ramadan happy e to everybody all over
the globe we have some other brothers
coming up we're also going to wish you a
happy Eid you're gonna see some martial
arts in this show we got a great episode
for you don't go anywhere we'll be right
back brother James peace be with you
Salt Lake o alaikum Salaam even body emo
bottom emo body I wanna wish everybody
an evening but that's right all over the
globe now you've got to experience
I mean you accept this Islam we've had
you on the program before several years
back
you're also a black belt in Gracie
Brazilian jiu-jitsu with teamraiser Vic
is that right that's correct and you
were fasting this month tell us about
the fest how was it this year the fest
for me this year was it was good it
actually made me feel better so I feel
more cleansed I feel refreshed and you
know people look at it like a month is a
long time it's really not a long time it
goes by so fast and like you see we're
at the eat so fast so fast right yeah so
you you reap the benefits definitely I
feel a lot better lighter healthier it's
helped a lot for the people that didn't
get to experience God Almighty gives us
like there's only one God he's the one
who decides when we leave this this
world so tell us for the people that
didn't we know Islam is based on five
pillars one is that you agree that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens on earth the
Muhammad is the last of final messenger
where should the Creator not his courage
it established a prayer five times a day
threat and it's a cat and then what we
did this month of fasting the fast so
many people are coming to this way of
life but some now are crass donating on
doing some of these pillars so for the
people who didn't get a chance to fast
this year
they make the right attention now
because they missing out what would you
tell them some words of encouragement to
prepare you know for next year because
it's right around the corner yeah my
only advice would be to start as soon as
you can don't be afraid to start gonna
be afraid to do it minute and it
actually helps you I think most people
they're hesitant to do it because of
their own fears or reserves but it's
it's prescribed for you because it's
better for you because it's good for you
so I advise people to do it when you
can't as soon as Ramadan comes around do
it it doesn't matter what's going on
just do it
we're in Ramadan now but I'm saying the
next Ramadan inshallah God ones around
the corner because the the last one but
you see how time is just for people some
people they can prepare themselves
mentally and physically months months
ahead of time by just fast in one day
here and there you know maybe just fast
part of the day so by the time Ramadan
comes around again you get acquainted
and accustomed to fast and so it won't
be as hard
you're also a black belt in Gracie
Brazilian jiu-jitsu tell us a little
about this how long you been training
you got a black belt now yes I do and
I've been training for quite a bit now
about 19 years here it feels good it's
an accomplishment a lot of years of
training but I'm more looking forward to
the years to come and Sharla the years
of training to come and the things that
I will learn so that I'm looking more
for today some people think that being
religious or anyone like to use the word
religious being spiritual you know
really having a fine balance in life
where okay you're not like locked in a
room all day just praying but you take a
time out to thank your creator because
he's the one to give you the ability
that you have to see to touch to feel
you know all the wonderful things so you
take a time out and you make the prayer
five times a day but also I mean you're
doing fun stuff you involved in sports
so it's a misconception that people have
it's a big misconception I think mainly
just because most people don't
understand
maybe the religion that they practice or
things like that it's a big
misconception you should go out into the
world
enjoy yourself within the means of the
religion but you can still do sports
it's a lot of things you can do it you
can't you can't get caught up on just
sitting home and you know
things you can't I can't do this I can't
do that cuz this is a lot of things that
you can do you can enjoy yourself
longest it's within the means so you
used to be also a former Christian you
accepted Islam how's it been has it been
challenging have you really gotten to
reap okay you just did the fast and you
benefited from that you're praying five
times a day many people now see you and
they say this guy's really looks like
you know normal guy trains he works he's
into sports you know and you're a Muslim
tell us your experience with Islam how's
it been so far thus far so for me the
the the transition it wasn't hard it was
pretty easy for me because my family is
my family actually there are several
religions in my family and there there
are Muslims in my family so I I knew
about the life and I know about the Dean
and I knew things that you know already
that should and shouldn't be done so it
was easy transition for me the only
difficulties I've had were from other
people you know with their own
misconceptions about Islam and stuff and
things like that but but for me it's
been easy I it I think for me this this
is Mark religion it's so easy nothing
I started fasting right away I'm able to
make Salah you know five times a day and
Shia and everything's come easy for me
but it's just people you know that they
try to say things and make things a
little difficult but I know that you
know a lot greater than anyone that's
walking around saying negative things
about me so I don't really think too
much about it so it's been easy that's
the beautiful thing when we work to
impress and to please our Creator and
still instead of looking back because
that's what holds people a lot of people
back from accepting the way of life from
the maker from the Creator the maker of
mankind is the peer pressure society
what people are gonna say now but I mean
you're doing something that's just in
people's nature you just worshipping the
crater not the creation you stay what
you're dieting what way you stay away
from alcohol poor gambling things that
are just bad for you anyway right what
else is your daily routine like my daily
routine is uh it's pretty fixed and I
try to stay with the routine you know I
wake up in shyla in the morning make
Salah you know
get up and uh do the normal things
everybody does I come in I try I try to
train as much as I can and throughout
the day you know five times a day that
makes a lot and it's pretty much just a
normal routine you know no problems and
that's it beautiful beautiful
so before we cut out this is Eid now
this is what we wouldn't wait for now we
fasted this whole month and it was like
a spiritual training ground you know at
this month you know people who came in
and they might have you know had a lot
of bad habits and now if you can
restrain yourself this month to give up
if a person was smoking if a person was
lying if a person was doing some some
some small sins major sins but now they
committed and they left it off hopefully
this is gonna be something that can
carry on you know after Ramadan so what
advice now do you have for those people
who also they feel like some of these
things that they're just they they make
the excuses like for instance salat
prayer or for fasting they make excuses
you know they're too busy work they
don't have time for it and maybe they
even born in Muslim families and they
didn't they're not praying they're not
fasting but you you came over from
Christianity you accepted Islam the
worship of the One God and now you're
doing all these things you reaping the
benefits but many they're they're just
making excuses and they're not getting
to experience all the good wonderful
things what advice do you have for the
advice that I have to everybody I've
said it before and it's something that I
really believe in and then I always say
it just simply just try to hold on to
the Rope hold on to the Rope of Allah if
you keep if when you have difficulties
in life you constantly keep turning back
to Allah whatever it whatever the
problem is you turn back you try to make
Salah you try to read some Quran you
just keep turning back to a lot just
like picture it picture a rope a rope
hanging down from the sky there anytime
you have difficulties anytime you have
any trouble you just grab the rope and
try to climb a higher and higher
there'll always be people always it
doesn't matter if you're doing something
good if you it doesn't matter if you're
doing something bad it doesn't matter
what you're doing there'll always be
people that has something negative to
say always but you have to look above
that look past that continue to try try
try try the best you can to be a better
person and just hold on to the Rope
that's the I think that's the best
advice
I advise but it's best always turn back
to Allah that's that's the secret and
that's the truth and some great advice
from our brother James stay strong stay
connected with your Creator do the good
that he wants us to do you want to have
a final Salam and Eid Mubarak again to
every bottle a come we want to miss
everybody even about it and have fun
that's right thank you again peace be
with you
I'll be right back with more this is the
theme this is the theme
[Music]
this is the thing
[Music]
back here on the D show we got another
treat for you another guest here Nadine
show Greg peace be with you
peace be with you smell like
waalaikumsalam mr. Nietzsche Eid Mubarak
Eid Mubarak we're finishing up the fast
one of the pillars of Islam and you got
to experience it again yes how's it been
Eid Mubarak Salam alaikum it's nice to
be here on the Deen show with brother
Eddie Ramadan is going good it's a it's
a beautiful time I think you can see
some of the best of the of the Muslims
during this time so you also accepted
Islam how long ago this is about seven
or eight years seven seven or eight
years ago and you actually went down to
Medina to study yeah yeah living
overseas studying in in the Muslim lands
yeah so now many people don't know a
Muslim is simply one who submits to the
will of God with Jesus a Muslim in my
liners the truth was a Muslim if someone
says how was Jesus a Muslim how's that
well Jesus is a prophet of God you know
he calls people to worship the one God
I know that there's a lot of debate on
the divinity of Jesus and things like
that but you know from our perspective
he's a prophet you know doesn't share
any divinity with God and God is God
Jesus is a creation of God and you saw
that you accepted Islam and you started
through the five pillars five pillars
one is to declared it there's nothing
worthy of worship except the crater
Muhammad is the final messenger that
would include Jesus Moses Abraham all
the preceding this and you that's what
makes someone a Muslim so accepted that
in the prayer five times a day minimum
right God don't need the prayer but we
need it because we need to be conscious
of God this is that system that he said
then the poor do tax and then the fast
that's that and what have you are you
starting to see because you've been
doing this for a little bit of a time
are you starting to see some people like
man why they got to give up food and
drink and you know all these things see
some Christina but you see the benefit
you see criticism from some people you
see understanding and you see personally
from doing it yourself you see the
benefits I mean from a physical
standpoint obviously there's health
benefits but of course the most
important thing is our intention you
know that we're doing this not because
doing wrong with that I want to lose
20 pounds but because this is something
that God asked me to do and I'm trying
to fulfill my obligations to our Creator
so we have to make sure we have the
right intention and it also gives you a
perspective because you know we're
blessed to be living here you know to
have these comfortable lifestyles and
there are many people in the world that
actually don't have this and things like
Ramadan really give you perspective of
that this is actually somebody's life
daily daily you know people are being
daily you know their stomach hurts
everybody gets the Ramadan you know
stomach cramps or stomach you know pings
of hunger yeah pangs and that's the
reality for some people everyday you
know not just one month so it really is
can be a humbling experience you know
definitely you know God Almighty says in
a verbatim word at word of god that
fasting has been prescribed on you as it
was prescribed in those before you so
Jesus fast all the message the best of
creation fast they worship only God and
we're continuing that same tradition
here with Islam submission to the will
of God so now we get to see also the
wisdom like you just expounded on you
know so people don't become miserly with
their money they get to experience what
it is to be hungry so now they'll be
more prone to to help those who are less
fortunate right it's a you know it's
equalizer it's a way to purify your
wealth and you know gives you a
perspective you know because if somebody
lives in a certain standard of life
their whole life they're not required to
make any sacrifices they might have a
different view of the world so I think
it's a great experience I know that
there are even many many non-muslims
that during the Ramadan they actually
partake in in the fasting you know and
some may even you know go to the prayers
and I definitely encourage brothers and
sisters to do that you know if you have
neighbors or co-workers you know during
Ramadan invite them to an iftar like a
family iftar is something where they can
be comfortable you know it's a great
opportunity to give them dowan you know
show them this way of life you're also
involved in in martial arts gracie
brazilian jiu-jitsu is that right with
team reza vick how's it going during
ramadan it's it's been going you know
it's been a little while I'm a little
bit rusty in my training but you know I
think if you're smart with what you eat
you know you're having the suhoor you
know you're getting sleep at the right
time you're not just you know burning
yourself out it's you know doing some
you know some activities some sports
some martial arts is very good you know
doing around with them there's nothing
wrong with it
you just got to really get hydrated in
the early morning before dawn yeah it's
not gonna be the same type of training
that you would you know normally but you
know doing something is good you know
having some kind of consistent schedule
even if it's light compared to your
normal schedule it's great especially
when you when you can do it with
brothers you know because everybody is
on the same schedule so you know that
after the night prayers let's go and
train for you know an hour a half an
hour you know then we can eat and you
know it's it's very a good time to find
with your brothers before we cut out we
did the special episode to which
everybody all over the globe a happy Eid
Ramadan Mubarak we know this is a
struggle it's a struggle to do good we
know that according to the last and
final messenger sent to mankind of her
Muhammad peace be upon him he said that
the Jenna the Paradise is surrounded by
undesirable things large ships and the
Hellfire is surrounded by you know the
other things that you know desire to
think the easy things so this is one of
those things that some people from the
outside they don't want to do you don't
want to do it right but it's one of
those things that it's good for you the
prayer is good for you the fasting is
good for you so now what do you have
what advice do you have for those people
who are going towards the bad things and
what do we say is surrounded by that's
what the hell fire surrounded by so we
don't want to have our brothers or any
of us and to the Hellfire we want to get
to Jenna so what it vice do you have for
people who are going towards the
nightclubs and drugs and fornication and
you know all the bad things yeah it's
little good this life is a test and the
trick is that we have to can
consistently remind ourselves you know
we may know what to test but if we're
not reminding ourselves and we're not
around people who are reminding us it's
easy to fall into bad habits to get into
the wrong crowd but if you're with your
brothers they're gonna check you you
know they're gonna whoa
no you're not we're not having any of
that funny business you know and that's
why it's really important for
communities for organizations you know
just for you as an individual Muslim you
know to do what you can to help your
brothers out you know to help your
sisters out you know even hope that you
know you're not with some friends out
you know by giving them that one and
showing them this way of life and one of
the best forms of Dao is is to personify
that you know so you have many people
many Muslims these days I know
unfortunately they're they're caught up
in the the western lifestyle the you
know this hedonistic lifestyle and we
just have to remember that life is short
you know I'm sure we can have these
things now but in the end is is it worth
it you know was that worth it to go to
that Club and you know engage in these
in these illicit activities when you can
have the same pleasures the right way
you know the way that is going to be
beneficial for your life and also is
going to be you know pleasing to your
Lord you know that willing so I
encourage my brothers and sisters you
know please try to have a good company
being good company
you know Ramadan shouldn't be a time
where you stop bad things just to start
them again when Ramadan stops I know
this is a big you know trend with many
people they're gung-ho during Ramadan
and once as soon as it ends they go all
the way back this is not what we're
going to do you know we want to leave
Ramadan you know once more one more step
forward hoping that we get to the next
Ramadan to make one more set so truly
you don't want to now give up let's say
person gave up alcohol just to go back
to alcohol give up cigarettes during
this month and if you could have stay if
you could stay away from alcohol or
drugs or fornication this month for a
whole month that proves that you can
stay away for good yeah and you know we
believe that that our Creator will open
a way for us yeah you know if we stop
doing the bad and we start striving
towards the good Allah will open up
doors for us and I've experienced that
personally I'm sure that you absolutely
absolutely do the good be good and God
will open doors of good that's right
thank you so much thank you very much
yes coming up hopefully he's in the
studio we're gonna get him all here we
go he's on the surprise-attack here so
we'll be right back with our next guest
wishing you a Happy eat even about it
even bodied everybody everybody is your
boss driving them crazy are you just
living from paycheck to paycheck party
to party and everything is just just
getting tiring it's getting played out
and you're asking yourself what's this
all about what's the purpose
many people don't reflect like I mean
why am I here you're born to die and
then what do you gotten in between me
it's a big drama some days are good some
days are bad some days you're sick some
days you're sad we not we might not make
it to 85 years old we might not make it
till tomorrow and this is something that
we need to think about the lights will
go on after the party and the party will
end and you will
you
[Music]
Eid Mubarak to everybody we got another
brother peace be with you wishing
everybody a happy eat how was your
Ramadan those awesome
can't complain the only thing is the
first few days were the roughest but
like anything in life the change you
know the first few days were the hardest
other than that after the first few days
it got easier you you adapted to it you
adapt to it and you made it exactly you
feel you're better now than when you
started
of course yeah of course of course you
were talking about before we we wanted
to bring as many people harder we can
find now to wish everybody a happy Eid
and you're also a professor of Brazilian
Jujitsu is that right yes underneath you
so tell us now you you mentioned
something about friends because we want
people if you've been this month leaving
off the bad company we want people to
stay with good company because birds of
a feather flock together and you said
something in the same basically with
something that we tell our students is
that you are the five people you hang
out with the most so if you hang out
with one guy a few other people and you
basically get a little bit of everyone
you hang out with so do your best if you
have someone that's negative most likely
he's gonna be a time vampire he's gonna
be I got coming to you hanging out with
you and start talking about negativity
so I'm really big on like not to hang
out with negative people because those
people start talking about problems and
they bring you down with you in this
before you know it one hour went by and
you just wasted how we're talking about
nonsense how about its problems yeah how
about people who are trying to get you
to smoke weed go to the bars exactly you
know hooking up with this person in that
person what do you think about that I
actually was I used to be in that
lifestyle and I had to like this there
is no still be friends with them and
this and that you just gotta cut them
off you just gotta let him go because
before you know it you're human and
you're gonna give in to your temptations
so yes you know
around you that's negative that's you
know talking nonsense or going partying
and doing all the other stuff consume
them away because they'll hold you down
you want to get to the top we want to
get to heaven you want to keep climbing
and whoever is holding you down negative
or anti that keep them away from you
that's it very good advice tell us
you've also your professor and Gracie
Brazilian Jujitsu has this also helped
you and do you encourage people to get
involved in martial arts and
self-defense you know and physical
activities my advice basically is go
trained Gracie jiu-jitsu if you had a
chance because this is the only martial
art that basically pushes your limits
pushes you it basically builds up your
confidence where you you don't care to
fail because you know partying being a
part of being successful is failing
people say oh I got tapped out I got
this I got choked triangled armbar
submitted so many times the only
difference between me and the other guy
that's a lower belt is that I I did a
lot of I did a lot more tapping and
failing until I got to the to my black
belt and before we go that's great
advice tell us you're very busy also
teaching at multiple academies do you
have time now and for the person who
makes excuses I have no time I'm so busy
but you all you make the time for your
prayer for your Salah for the connection
with the Creator is that right how do
you fit that in with all this busy
lifestyle you have yes it's only a
couple minutes take it out a couple of
minutes out of the day five times a day
does that help you stay connected you
know with this whole rat race of life
when you make that prayer does that help
you stay focused now
not to get too consumed with the
material world yes because you get
caught up in this like you said the rat
race and you've sometimes you get
stressed out or whatever the case is and
then you go back to LA and this is this
is I'm not bringing this money with me
or I'm not I'm not this this is this is
just a we're just passing we're just
travelers so don't forget that this life
is too short right it'll be gone
tomorrow that's right yeah so okay last
last closing comments advice emo biotic
you want to send everybody another even
about it I'm about it to all the Muslims
in the world and not yet Muslims try it
out you know log on to the Deen show and
make sure to if you have a Facebook guys
that
Muslims have a Facebook make sure you
like our statuses and and share our
things because you never know that one
person they shared one of our videos to
Eddie's videos actually
you never know that person might change
and end up becoming Muslim and then you
can reap the rewards of everything that
person have learned has learned from
your share or I think that's right I
don't know if that so like us like the
Facebook Twitter and Malo us on Twitter
and one last thing I want you guys to
put pause right now Chris pause wait
hold on don't put pause yet go subscribe
if you have us YouTube subscribe to
Eddie's utility show that angel with a
digital TV yes subscribe right now pause
good go do it do it right now don't
don't say tomorrow do it now
that's right and he's right everyone has
the potential to submit to the will of
God to submit to the Creator that's what
a Muslim is one who does the will of
their maker so yes if you are one who
shares some of our programs and someone
accepts this way of life that all the
messages of God live and they start
praying and doing good and being good
you get the reward without diminishing
any from them that's right make sure to
share the videos you like don't go two
months without sharing try to share it a
few times a month and invite people
subscribe subscribe subscribe thank you
very much for being with us we'll be
right back peace
you
and thank you for joining us on this
special episode Ramadan is over we got
Eid right now happy e to everyone all
over the globe this month it was a
spiritual training ground for us to be
better human beings so the bad habits
that we got rid of during Ramadan we
don't want to go back to him so if you
were used to smoking if you were used to
drinking not praying and now you were
praying this month you establishes the
prayer you were leaving off alcohol you
gave up the girlfriend or the boyfriend
and now you it's counterproductive now
you're gonna go back to that now you
don't want to go back to that you want
to stay on track because death is a
reality like we always mention and we
can die tomorrow the crater says in the
Quran o you who believe how
consciousness of your Lord who your Lord
and do not die except in a state of
submission to him so you don't want to
get caught in the nightclub and death
reaches you and then it's finished
bye-bye
so you've did a wonderful thing we've
done a wonderful thing we fasted this
month for the pleasure of a creator and
let's stay on track live in Islam
submission to the will of God to the
maker of mankind doing good being good
and for those people who are watching
that Deen show and you like what we got
to say and you want to worship the
Creator not his creation you want to do
good you want to get to paradise because
his life is short
give us num they'll give us a call this
number 1 800 662 lat sit for this
episode of the V show we started with
peace because we're people of peace and
happy Eid Eid Mubarak to everybody all
over the globe from my family to yours
Eid Mubarak Eid Mubarak eating body